Los Seguidores de los higos de
Filadelfia y los chips de Kansas City
llegaron a Arizona en la víspera de la
final del Super Bowl aficionados de los
equipos de fútbol americano viajaron
para asistir al evento deportivo anual
más importante de Estados Unidos también
pagaron grandes cantidades de dinero
para el evento
si superara los 10 mil dólares
probablemente tendría problemas en casa
pero si puedo mantenerlo por debajo de
5000 está bien pero tengo un coche de
alquiler y un hotel y ya sabes estoy a
punto de ir a buscar algo de comida aquí
en Phoenix Así que ya sabes
probablemente serán 8 o 9 mil dólares el
fin de semana
no solo Los tiquetes implican dinero
este año la venta de espacios
publicitarios difundidos durante el
evento alcanzó precios récord 7 millones
de dólares por 30 segundos de anuncio
una pregunta muy común es vale la pena 7
millones de dólares por 30 segundos
porque haría esto una marca el primero
es que es una audiencia masiva oscila
alrededor de 100 millones más o menos es
mucha gente a la que hablar al mismo
tiempo pero es más que eso durante el
Super Bowl la mayoría de los
consumidores están entusiasmados con los
anuncios y quieren hablar de los
anuncios
el muy esperado espectáculo del medio
tiempo está este año a cargo de Rihanna
el Super Bowl es uno de los mayores
escenarios del mundo así que por mucho
miedo que me dé porque hace 7 años que
no subo a un escenario hay algo
estimulante en todo este reto
se espera que un 20% de la población
estadounidense apuesta una cifra récord
de aproximadamente 16 mil millones de
dólares sobre la final del